greetings from podcast Ville the
cheering - what's happened now is
brought to you by zip recruiter listen
hiring is challenging but there's one
place you can go we're hiring it's nice
and simple fast and smart a place where
growing businesses connect to qualified
candidates that place is zip recruited
calm right now do me a favor right now
to the church family this is what I'm
gonna do fear alright because I love you
you know you know I'm always trying to
make you people a little extra extra
little cash put some powerful in your
market zip recruiter send your job to
over 100 of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there okay so it
results like that it's no wonder that
zip recruit is the highest rated hiring
site in America what I'm gonna do for
the church family right now is I'm gonna
let you try zip recruiter for free for
free for free at zip cool.com slash
Church that zipper google.com slash
Church again for the cheap seats that's
super cool calm slash Church the
smallest way to hire number two let me
tell you son you're sitting there you're
hungry you listen to the podcast you're
thinking about what he's gonna do for
dinner what I'm gonna do in my life
okay we're gonna do your life blue apron
you're looking at me Joey what's boy
pandu blue apron delivers farm-fresh
ingredients and step-by-step recipes
including your door you understand me
what'd you get last week Lee oh I got
some amazing stuff I got steak and
cheese subs I've gotten Korean beef
balls are delicious that's what I'm
talking about
skip me you're planning it straight to
cooking with blue egg but now what I'm
gonna do is this check out this week's
menu and get your first three meals for
free free gratis on the arm nothing near
take at blue apron dot-com / Joe again
that's boy Pandavas last Joey to get
your first three meals for free blue
apron a better way to cook
take that meal Lee the church what's
happening now what's happening a little
problem why don't you do you know you
texted me yesterday little brother a
little dis little bad I know but the
thing is is that just cuz I'm smaller
than you doesn't mean I'm
that is hardcore thank you
thank you big brother box Thank You
babies whatever thank you for that
brother I want to live I want you to
understand and we've known each other
for so long you know why me you know
lucky you and I are how you know like I
told you two weeks ago I worked with
shame you say Matan shame I XM you know
she was my roommate she was your Roomba
yeah yeah in 97 yeah didn't land these
six whatever the [ __ ] it was you know
I'm watching her on stage doing a little
[ __ ] impersonations and doing her
thing and she's killing yes Joan Rivers
if you have all that said I'm like you
know what that's 20 years that's 20
years so if I talk to shame attached I
still talk to you like I love you
because something happened to you I
would be really small do you would you
cry which are all really sad I get
really sad how many like for a week for
a little life it'd be like I think the
people I've lost already or something
happens when you're a comedian bro with
all the hatred in this town all the
stupidity when two comics from the store
like I saw you I think Thursday I
followed you and sadly you followed me
like I had to follow each other and both
nights I drove home let go I don't
understand if Bobby knows how lucky he
is
because yeah people know that a manager
took us out to dinner in San Antonio
yeah in 98 at the Latino laugh fest and
water broke but know that it's been 20
years that was still in the game to know
that we're still relevant that we still
get spots at the [ __ ] store yeah did
you have you ever thought about that
that you still get spots at the store
well I think I'm in my case dude I'm
kinda like a weasel bro I'm kind of like
a cockroach I know how to like get into
other people's worlds but but I do it in
ways like either through guilt or
sadness I am a trickster you know mean
so it's like when I wasn't getting spoon
Adam first took over I wasn't getting a
lot of spots and I just kind of you know
got sad I wouldn't talk to him for like
a week and then he's you know but I do I
do little tricks like that how many
spots you get a week I get every night
every day and perform anywhere else but
the school yeah plain ol a factory
sometimes now but like yeah mostly the
stores your heart took the store or God
might do my dicks at the storm wrong I
might do I'm tell you right now do that
if the comedy stores closed I wouldn't
know where to [ __ ] go bro
you know we dad would switch governments
and go to an improv I mean I would do
you try to keep odds there maybe but you
know you know dude these clubs don't
have like a home group you need a home
group you need guys because I like the
stories you can't it's so hard to get in
you know I know a bunch of dudes are
like can you get me in like establish
students and I bring them over and then
the dude get Adams like nah right so
then it makes me realize all it's almost
impossible I like the exclusive video BD
of it how could she presides out out of
it I know she took 20 [ __ ] out
of that I could have changed the world
with that comedy but she kept Pryor she
kept you know when she to a lot of
people out of it and let people know
that you couldn't [ __ ] around with it
yeah like I've always taken that place
very seriously like I was a [ __ ]
straight like Esther I remember pulling
up up there and seeing cases of booze
out yeah like that get dropped often up
like 10 years ago I would have put these
in my car and sold them on Sunset a 50%
of them I couldn't imagine doing that at
the store like I didn't want to [ __ ]
around at all up there every life
experience that's a valid in my life was
through there
my first three so you know where I had
like my first somebody eating my
butthole or like seeing seeing ghosts I
saw it the Communists don't really saw
girls two times me and Johnny Sanchez
saw at the same time a ghost whether you
see your ghost what do you mean it's
only what there's only one room there's
only one ghost there bro the belly and
his name is Gus do you know that is that
his name that's his name bro
Gus dude I've seen guys twice Brian
where did you see Gus the first time I
saw Gus was Johnny Sanchez you know that
little Latino class absolutely yeah you
go there bro I go what's up let's do a
gig in Bakersfield so back in the day I
used to have this truck with no window
the windows were blasted open and no
so I parked my truck at the Comedy Store
he takes his car we drive to Bakersfield
we do a show on the way back it's like
3:00 in the morning now when he drops me
off at my car
we're standing in the parking lot she's
talking about the night or whatnot and
we both look up at that top window and
we see a face glowing no eyes no no
features wearing a top hat and two hands
against the window looking down on us we
look we look at the thing we look at
each other again and we look back up
it's gone and we believed that to be Gus
my friend that was the first time what
was the second I was playing the piano
at 4:00 in the morning it's a great room
yeah why you laughing dude I haven't
really heard anyone say that in the main
room bathroom people can say they play
the the Comedy Store opinion or the way
I play the back that bathroom that yeah
that piano back there yeah but back then
it wasn't in back there it was on the
side of this on the side of this thing
right so it's completely dark right and
I'm playing with my own improvised
little you know Korean lullaby
you know I'm being don't think I'm ding
ding ding dong ting tong ting tong ting
tong yeah stuff like that and I look to
my right and I see the yellow suit with
a top hat but from far away you know
where the entrance is
I see it coming toward me I run out that
back door you know that word to the
hallway yeah and I come back and it's
gone and that I believe that to be my
second encounter with Gus now I had one
encounter but it wasn't with Gus who is
it I think I thought it was Sam Tennyson
it's so funny that you say that because
once you say this what you're saying I
want to tell you something about Sam and
guts go ahead yeah don't tell me what
well Carla Bo you know Carla Baum yes
Carla Bo and Sam Kinison were best
friends
in fact when Sam Kinison died Carla Bo
held his body did you know that as he
was saying no it's not my time to be I
had that whole thoughts
don't make me cry right now no could you
almost be bright just myself don't do
that okay you almost got me there but
anyway um Carla was telling me because I
got it
teeth fix do you know that back in the
day when I can when I started getting
making money in showbiz well he came up
to me and he opened his mouth and it was
like boom Shakalaka in his mouth like
death crawler blow
no yeah he'd open his mouth and it's
something was rotting in his mouth I go
what's the matter he goes my tooth
that's not what he sounds like
but he goes my dude what's wrong I want
you to because it's rotting and I went
and got his teeth fixed but during that
time right he was telling me a story how
when him in Sam Kinison moved here from
Houston it was they would sleep in the
main room on the stage and one night
Carl and Sam were sleeping and Carl was
awoken - Sam Kinison levitating upside
down from the stage in Congress what you
know you how big Sam is right and then
he was dropped on his back but he was
definitely like four feet up from the
stage and they believed that it was Gus
that was doing that Gus apparently was a
bodyguard or a doorman back when it was
zeros and he was assassinated there and
he's like a mafia hit man his ghost and
he's angry what's the matter
why you staring at me like that Princess
Cory I saw oh I thought was Kennison I
was in the original room yeah okay so I
went I was I'd like a 1245 spot the
original and Saturday night this is the
old days the place has happened I hear a
voice in the main room there's a show
going on the mainland on the Saturday
night I walk up and it's old that I know
Mitzi's in her chair and their booth
they're bowing at that I didn't go in I
stand in the hallway but something when
I was looking at the comic so the main
room is that TV the mainland stage is
that TV I'm in the hallway something
kept blocking the light from the belly
room that was shining in the wall hmm so
every time I would watch something would
block it and I finally know what the
[ __ ] is this my step back and I looked
up
and what I saw was what you see you do I
don't want to say no you have to what I
saw was a guy look at me but before I
could see his face or what he had in his
head he threw a cape over and he wasn't
to evaluate that was Goss dude and I was
like Jesus Christ I finally saw my first
goes at the store that's it it done
so this wears a top hat and a cape now
princess Cory has don't doubt it done
princess Cory Hannah story about getting
[ __ ] up at the store and going into
the main room when it was dead you know
we first saw today there was no main
room shows comedy chaos I'm Tuesday yeah
it was skyla stoner on Thursday it was
on Friday and senator was open but every
night night was it was very dark
we've got hosed out Tuesday oh they had
was black night yeah besides that it was
completely dead princess Cory told me a
story one day she was on the up and up
her and I were eating late lunch or
something and she told me that that's
the first time she told me she was out
of this place is definitely [ __ ]
haunted like what are you talking about
she goes one that I got really [ __ ]
hammered and I figured I'd go into a
mainland before sleep one of that the
boots she goes I just wanted to but she
wasn't thinking like that for an hour
sleep it off and wake up she was I was
awakened to [ __ ] ballroom music wow
plastic in the Comedy Store crepe and
she said she popped her head up in the
whole dance the whole mainland stage was
people dancing with top hats and jackets
on like just dancing and that she got
like this right now
yeah set the alarm off Wow cops came you
know the manager at the store came at
the time she was the talent coordinator
at the time this is before Freddie I
think I rest his soul she goes that the
cops came they couldn't find nothing but
I have been out in that white many a
night again in those days I was some
type of drug and so I cannot the night I
was watching the mainland sure I was not
on drugs
I was still had a spot trial not do
cocaine yet so what I saw that night I
saw yeah
I've seen two ghosts in my life I
a ghost at the comedy store and I saw a
ghost when I was about four in the
building in new year member that over
for yes I still remember what I felt
like ice to remember telling my mother
the confusion that I had and I still him
my mother asking me the story over and
over and over again like a cop to make
sure I wasn't [ __ ] crazy and then
when I moved into 35:15 given that
Terrace there was a time when I was when
I got on a Catholic school I couldn't
stay in that house Bobby Lee you know I
couldn't stay in the house at night yeah
I've been on a big one you know but you
know the type of guy I love to be
independent so when I got in the
Catholic school when I got in a Catholic
school my mama had a bar yeah so that
meant basically I had the house to
myself at night what 12 year old kid
what 12 year old kid doesn't want a
house to himself with cable TV every
everything every kid wants a house to
himself I would go home at night my
mother would cook dinner
I would eat dinner with her she'd leave
to the bar I would do my homework
watch gets Kristi love whatever show was
popular in those guys go up to my room
ten o'clock put the air on go to sing
and within 20 minutes I'd be awoken by
something Bobby leave this one on for
[ __ ] a year that I couldn't sleep I
would [ __ ] test torch and I would
feel something I would just end one
night as I can't do this level there's
something in this [ __ ] house and I
remember telling my mother my stepfather
and people like you crazy you're
watching too many horror movies
and I [ __ ] started living with a
family I'm just going to a house at
night I played basketball with the kids
and then the parents didn't have a
[ __ ] clue was the next house at night
so you couldn't sleep I would go to my
mother's bar
stamp my mother's box online do homework
eat dinner with my mother
and then go to 26 streets in the central
they were Puerto Rican family name the
Torres's and I was someone I was a
tourist boppo and I go to his room we'd
watch TV and nobody would know I was
able to sleep in this house I get up in
the morning brushed my teeth combed my
head and go to North Bergen school so I
would stay in Union City can go to
school North Bergen the [ __ ]
point of the story is yeah but after my
mother died and I found the dead there
the whole thing I found that an
interesting [ __ ] story so people came
over after my mom died and they said
we're really sorry about your mom's
death and they said you know what we
never write this house anyway we've
thought about buying this house but you
know why this house sold for cheap
because somebody hung themselves in the
garage and right there I knew that all
my premonitions that I had I would hear
it Bobby Lee I'm gonna read that I'm not
a [ __ ] idiot Bobby Lee I know what I
see and I know what I feel how would he
feel somebody going up the steps that's
what I would feel people running up the
steps or running down the stem self was
they were they white I had no idea you
have to know that [ __ ] do you have to
know that yeah probably New Jersey you
would think so I thought he hung himself
for years
I heard the room cuz after like my
mother died they buried it and these
people who had lived on the block I knew
like I wasn't friendly with them yeah
they came that day and were like we
looked at this house first it was like
ten thousand dollars cheaper yeah but
somebody killed him selves my garage so
they said he hung himself and then I
told somebody and they came back to me
hold on we did some looking the guy was
one of those guys that closed the garage
ooh
and put the [ __ ] car on the car so
anytime I go back to that house I can
Schley and I shot the documentary I
could feel that house like I was
thinking about buying that house but
that still there I'm buying that house
it still there yeah it's still there I'm
thinking of going back to North Bergen
saying what do you want for this house
an orphan $20,000 more got that house
gotten it from A to Z gut cleaning out
the outside I know this [ __ ] in the yard
I know there's weapons hidden in the
yard my stepdad is still there I know
they're still there yeah I hid a gun in
85th Street I know it's still there
right talk to the people you
[ __ ] gonna find that gun
yeah I said by the garage he had to be
like three feet in but there's something
about 35:15 given that Terrace it's
always bothered me still till today
my mother died there I found her in the
kitchen you know what that house had
become well who lives there now a family
would me and we were their older
Hispanic family but older family but
they had had it's my mother died we
husband that's Barbie oh that's the you
are Leon yeah that's my bad dude no
worries you told his name with Jimmy I
don't remember but is the whole Tyler
thinking what the [ __ ] this guy's name
is yeah really what's up see when Lee
and I wish of the documentary some
people came Lee or no I think the people
bought that house when your mother died
they like they were the first people
that bought it and they still live there
but I would like to buy that house and
there's nothing you can do they'll tear
it down no even if you build something
about up in that that the ghost is still
there no no I could do something you
could bring like Indian chiefs [ __ ] yeah
dance on [ __ ] I know my mother's in that
house I know my mother's tormented in
that house I know that she's in there I
would give her peace of mind I've always
thought about that and I can't believe
how cheap the problem I like my friend's
dad died he's got a two-floor [ __ ]
house in North Bergen it's $40,000
yeah North Bergen is a throw rock from
New York City it's still safe the house
the neighborhood is safe everything's
safe you would have to tear the house
down and build a new house but Robbie
Hey communicating with the dead and
stuff you know you're getting into
Snowden I say I want to communicate with
nobody listen you know but you wanna
wait what do you wanna do I would like
to buy that house that house meant a lot
to me I know but the thing is this is
that no matter what you do with the
house you tear it down you wipe it out
you build something else on that the
spirits are still there you believe that
yeah it's not in the wall it's not in
the con what makes you believe that just
just a mucker it's you because it'll
argue with you you know we're dealing
with a different plane my friend okay
they're on both planes right do you have
this again to go to the second plane
take some some the machine may be Duncan
Trussell knows about one no no which
cubed the cubits call El Mundo
then I would get that that they wouldn't
get down the road of of truth yeah I
understand that but I figured whatever
was haunting me listen Bobby Lee
you blood dick to the drugs you bill
addicted to drugs you started hearing
things that's right I've been addicted
to drugs oh I started hearing things for
27 years you know it's a mental prison
that's the easiest way to describe an
addiction people were going through
opioids whatever you going through my
heart goes out there and you know I love
you you know I'm telling you the truth
that it's a mental present you can't be
reliable you're not reliable no more you
and I both know it's a mental prison but
I still believe in the spirituality why
did you you know what like well I did
The Longest Yard where we shot the
lonely shot in New Mexico yeah there was
a riot at that prison they killed seven
guards and they shut the power down and
when they turned the power on people
thought that there was water it was
blood it was a stream of blood from all
the people that had killed until this
day they took the blood out and they
paint the floor here but there was so
much blood on the floor that the Bloor
the blood still comes up from the prison
so tell me this about because when we
shuffle long as yard there they found
out about that that paramount did so
paramount didn't want no [ __ ]
problems so they said to Swami a Hindu a
Catholic priest they come kidding you an
Indian embrace this everyone for every
everybody every religion they sent them
down they'd do a cleanse the funny thing
was the producers wanted to make sure so
they offered anybody who spent the night
in the prison you know a thousand bucks
and the [ __ ] nobody spent the night
everybody would run out an hour and
because they heard boys you know Mitzi
though right rights he hired an a
cleaner from Paris every year for like
30 years to clean her office because
there was a apparently like things would
levitate and crash against the walls in
her office have you been inside her
office yes I've never seen it and I've
been there for 25 years I don't think
I've seen the inside of that office now
yes you've seen the inside inside that
office I thought that I thought no one
was alive this was 15 years ago when she
used to come in three times a week I
never said I was a telemarketer upstairs
with a hey Clint okay but they she would
clean it every year
and they would say it still wouldn't be
clean no one could clean it so what I'm
saying is is that who knows that these
things these Hindus and these like you
know cleaners can do anything well
here's the deal I was at the store one
afternoon I used to do Bobbo shacks job
who would before that was for any solos
job and what you did was you basically
[ __ ] drove you went to get her a
tongue sandwich you went to the hardware
store and you made deposits at the bank
yeah that was your job well and you
picked up shifted a little Mexican
carpenter is he still there yeah yeah
yeah I love him love him he's gotten but
he's doing well in life so he's a little
fatter is he is she has more cheeks I
gotta go see him April are you doing
yeah he would be down there ten after
them yeah I like that she forgot his
name what's his name Toby leo yeah
whatever when I was there one day
waiting to go on a mission and the
weirdest thing happened a van pulled up
like a handicapped man you know and had
to be 19 had to be 2000-2001 baby it's
gotta be 2:00 in the afternoon and his
van pulls up guy gets out of the car
color looks like me little thinner and
he opens up the two doors and he puts a
wheelchair guy in the ramp and he
presses a button and the ramp pushes it
out and the guy walks up and uh me very
friendly the guy he goes how you know
like how are you doing if I was 40 38 at
the time the guy had to be 80 yeah five
this handler was about 40 45 they were
very nice but the guy asked me blatantly
goes' mitzi here but I don't know you
know I don't know nothing you know me I
don't know I don't know it's easier and
he goes she gonna say that you were
conveniently yeah I'm trying you know
yeah I'll put the pieces together sir
hey I don't know what the guy did but he
goes I was one of the original
door been here when it was zeros whoa
admits he ever find the money do you
know she ever found the money downstairs
whoa
and I was like I have no [ __ ] idea
and then the guy rolled behind me and I
don't know if he saw him it's II know
you're saying to me right now is in the
basement of the basement there could be
money stashed away yes because you know
that you can get down there now people
hang out yeah yeah we gotta find it yes
but I heard that this I heard that you
could go downstairs and sneak out all
the way to the street behind it no yes
that that is a tunnel there's a tunnel
because oh yes because the guy who owns
eros smuggled [ __ ] what's his name zero
no the guy who owns zeroes was a
gangster oh that kid Bugsy Siegel a
buggy's Bugsy Siegel was who created a
Las Vegas yeah who Bugsy Siegel and came
out to Vegas they thought he was rub his
shoulders at the wrong people he was
again little a little [ __ ] in the
smoochy and he was dating a Hollywood
starlet and plus the envelopes were a
little whiter in Las Vegas the mat
didn't add up
yeah yeah I gave you eight million but I
got six million in contractor retreats
meanwhile you're in LA having dinner
with [ __ ] Sinatra I'm over here in
Buffalo eating meatball sandwiches with
a Korean and the fat will [ __ ]
jeweler to the thighs Lee so Lee yeah
yeah what's it say who owns Sara I think
you know I think it was Bugsy Siegel who
owns Searles and rejoin so they would
kill people there that's what I'm saying
that would kill people yeah and that's
the result of it people got tortured
there yeah they had a room down there
would they would torture people Plus and
in the belly room too was an illegal
abortion center did you know that no
yeah there was an illegal abortion
center and that's why they call it the
belly room Jesus Christ and that's why
at times that people have said this if
they do spend the night there you can
hear babies crying upstairs but can I
just tell you something about that belly
room also and it brings up something the
scariest thing I've ever seen up there
one night at 2:00 in the morning I was
hanging out there okay and they go don't
you know you
but upstairs they're doing something but
you can't I go up there in the belly
room
I gots clothes who gives a [ __ ] he's
like there's something going up there do
not go up there but I went up there at
the end of the back entrance
we were up the block I opened up that
back thing right all that it's pitch
black in there but I see candles right I
swear to God I saw this 15 people
wearing hoods and purple cloaks okay and
they're chanting I got Gemma Connie a
pecan that bon nuit
right and then so I go back downstairs
and I wait to see who they come down
after the seance
you know I saw one of them was Lily
Tomlin okay the second one was Bob zmuda
you know Bob zmuda and they were saying
on seeing Andy Kaufman's ghost did it
work and I don't know I didn't I didn't
stay up there long enough to know but
what I'm saying is is that there's
something about that belly room that is
a portal of something why are you
laughing it's just crazy the comedy club
in its youth like a haunted house living
in 35:15 being a child not a child be
the teenager and staying in on Friday
nights to watch Sanford and Son and
their will used to be a show called
Ripley's believe in that yeah go to you
first find out who owns 0 so yeah it was
the last one tone and he wrestled it
away from there we go so Bugsy was there
was there ever a Serie open that owned
it no the first owner was William
Wilkerson but his nickname was zero
thought of it but the people rental it
after he did what commit went to Sammy
Shore and said if you wanna start a know
what was the second one say no what was
the second thing naughty do you know uh
I think maybe we're police believe it or
not yeah go to youtube and see if you
find before you get him into that I
wouldn't just say I'm gonna last the
last point I wanted to make
Jesus there is something dark about the
store it's not because it's black
there's just something a weird vibe
there a lot of comics even though we're
having an upswing there's this girl who
she hasn't I'm not gonna name her name
because I wanna get in trouble but she
has a Netflix special but she doesn't
play the store and I was at the Laugh
Factory and I saw her perform and she
got offstage I was right after her and
never met her before she very funny and
I said you're very funny and she goes
like this you got it she just walks away
from me
right which is rude right so in my head
I'm thinking maybe it's in my head and
then check it out the next week I'm at
The Improv and she's sitting there
because she's about to go up I sit next
to her she walks up and walks away so I
did some investigating and I go with
this girl you know she she avoids me and
I've never met her before I never talked
[ __ ] behind her back and a bunch of
comics were saying oh yeah she anyone
that works at The Comedy Store she won't
even talk to like oh why because she
think believes that every we're all like
kind of like demons and they were all
like a part of this weird comedy cult
that were dark we have dark energies but
I don't feel that I pray at night and
you know I try to be good right we are
but do you think that people do believe
that though when I got here
we're on the street was industry would
not go to the Comedy Store yeah and
industry would stay away from you if you
had something to do with the Comedy
Store because you would drug-involved
there's something like that there was
all a bunch of things are there I know
one thing and I know one thing about you
Bobby Lee The Comedy Store affected both
of us in for the better or the worse for
the worst at first to bring out the
better whoa what the [ __ ] does that mean
you know the other night I was sitting
at one of the morning I went down to the
store and I found one Jill had watched
you and
I got my car then having a hard time
lately Bobbili if you want me to lie to
you my brothers I could take the last
two years I've struggled with people
willing to take pictures with me I've
struggled with people that send me
emails and say you know you and we're
changing our why's the [ __ ] you
talking about
I'm a [ __ ] criminal jack I'll put a
gun to your [ __ ] head take your
wallet right now you all know you wanna
believe in that that's who I was I never
doesn't know I wouldn't be of that
working about my ex-wife I was really
thinking about my ex-wife what about
life and now she saw me at my worst
there was many few he would be that saw
me at my worst a guy I kidnapped
obviously my ex-wife this guy named Mike
Roebuck from he's in a welfare he's
called into the show a couple times he's
my brother
there's very few George Callaghan ski
was my brother he was dead and that I
kidnapped a guy and he saw me do a bunch
of dark stuff you know I was always a
dark guy before I got to the store
that's not [ __ ] the mistake who the
[ __ ] we are him but when I got to the
store it does something to you the
original room does something to you
the main new does something teen that
affects you I don't know if you know
this do you remember when I got the fat
wall on my neck oh yeah yeah yeah and I
would get my I would do a line of coke
in my heart would pump yeah whenever my
heart would pump the fat wall will come
out of my collarbone it would just
levitate likes Kennison on this spirit
and you can only feel it so after I got
off stage and my heart would work up I
go Bobby Lee come in and you touch this
girl yeah everybody know the hospital
yeah check that I do remember that how
are you people touch it though because I
wanted you to tell me that I needed to
get help cause I was too much of a [ __ ]
to go to the [ __ ] huh that was you're
under development twinned yes like a 20
that's all was up my toe in my head what
was this some of it that I checked the
speed freak with the boyfriend Josh
douche away in the band he had Holmes my
hump my little I had this [ __ ] hump
so I went out to see the CERN I both
they they took it out and here's the
funny thing there's two things that
happen to me that can validate what
you're saying to me this is the first
thing bobbing your leash in your pants I
didn't know you were spiritual as you
were when I came out of the surgery the
doctor came in he knows how you feel
he was listen we had a zip a piece of
your [ __ ] collarbone
we removed the piece of your collarbone
because what we thought was in there
wasn't really in it it was a lot bigger
it was the size of a [ __ ] softball
your collarbones gonna be a little soft
but we did this new type of medical
you're not never gonna feel it which I
never have you can't even find the scar
I'll give you a hundred bucks did not
they were beautiful they're technologies
Biju's are beautiful but in the
conversation he goes do you want to see
what was in you yeah Bobby Lee I swear
to God your mind works in mysterious
ways as soon as the doctor came in it
was a jar you ever see the movie the
Charlie jerk would oh the man with the
brains
what's that Steve one movie with
animality brains but yeah hey Johnny it
was a jar like that with the fat ball oh
my god at the bottom half capsule in
fact no yeah the bottom half was still
intact and the top half was what he
broke off when he was first pulling it
and I looked at it and this is the first
thing I thought about Bobby Lee and
you're ready all the times you walked in
the comedy store after you booked
something and people came up this and
Bob a [ __ ] we love you and as you
walked away they said [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] him he ain't funny ain't
never said that they all you have to
assume they do wine because that was
their thinking back then he was like
[ __ ] [ __ ] well whatever they said when
you when I first got to there was a
little dose of jealousy that jealousy is
not in them when I try the Comedy Store
so great right now do you know why
though why is it I'll tell you why
because at some point Mitzy yes approved
people that didn't belong all right and
now you're mixed in with people that
don't belong with the people that do and
the people that don't belong to believe
that they go [ __ ] that guy
can you explain why they don't belong
they just don't have it they don't have
that extra did that thing you and you
know what Joe Rogan told me that the
other day he looked at me and he goes
there's something about you you have it
there's nothing he goes off your mind I
said the same yeah there's nothing
there's no science and anything you just
you just have it in that guy over there
doesn't have it and there's nothing
about upbringing it's not about it and I
go wow that's interesting but I believe
that some people just are born with this
thing that they have it and I can I can
seek young guys now I bring them on the
road I look at him and I go and I think
this guy has it let me ask you a
question yes what about the guys that
had it when you and I were starving to
death yeah
and now they're with us and they don't
have it what are you safe for those guys
because there's always because now I'm
Asian about it but I'm science about it
I'm scientific proof you they were hot
for three years you've been hot for ten
years you've been doing this now you've
been on a television show this is your
maybe what your mom cast its position
well no I mean I've been I've done
pilots was my third only my third on air
show probably episodes of Mad I did
eight years you know that certification
I did a year on animal practice and now
I'm on my second year of splitting up
together you like the wife from Mary
with children she went from man with
children I don't know just a period
Dalek you just keep getting syndication
you just keep getting changed but do you
know why but do you know why I think
it's there's two reasons number one I
never left the store and for any reason
reason number two yeah in number two I
got sober right so that's all I have and
also number three I still read a lot of
these guys like I'm gonna get name his
name but there was a guy on the guy back
in the day used to be in a lot of movies
like Oh what happened he but why I won't
read they have to offer it to me and in
my head I'm like Halle
I'm like no you have to you have to go
in sign up and you have to wait in that
Lobby and then read and get reject
did and that's what the game is I love
it yeah I love there's nothing I haven't
told my wife I miss do you love a woman
even when you first got here and we're
green green green when you went in to
audition troops who are the Asians in
those rooms on my huge now oh no dude
what's this what no for number one
what's this there's two stories number
one when I first got into town the kind
of parts that I would get is like you're
a ninja and I would sure I would show up
at the audition and there'd be 40 fools
there wearing the ninja outfits but with
the masks but I didn't have one and I'd
come in here and I go I'd go into the
audition they go where's your outfit
okay I don't know no one [ __ ] ninja I
think okay well then you're not gonna
get it right that's what it was but the
first time I saw all the heads like John
Chow Daniel Dae Kim all those guys was
during the audition of King Kong now if
you watch Peter Jackson's King Kong
there's one choice he's true did it no
lines and he just runs from that's his
part right but let me tell you something
they read for that part people read and
that was one of them so I show up and
there's like 80 you know well
established now Asian heads but back
then we had nothing nothing right you
walk into the room and they had a
cardboard cutout of King Kong on the
wall I'd love to see you run away from
King Kong I feel like you do a good job
yeah so racist yes this is so many all
right so I'm just gonna be running in a
circle and King Kong's chasing after you
I swear to [ __ ] god I go what do I
say nothing no just runs you know so I I
start running in the circle I don't say
nothing I'm just running in a circle and
then she'll stop she goes do you gotta
yell you scream it there's a King Kong
like all right action I go ah in a
circle she goes stop you don't seem
Chinese I go what do you mean when
you're yelling you don't seem like Asian
so you know what I did I swear to God I
did this she go
action I start running ah and I leave
and now I'm almost crying and I have
sweat dripping down my face and I'm
walking out and I see John Cho everyone
and they have to go in there too but you
know what I do I don't leave I sat there
for four hours just to see the faces
coming out of that room
of complete sadness and distraught and
this is Hollywood
I mean this is Holly this is what we get
in Hollywood
you have no idea for people hope say
what'd he say cuz it feels like somebody
slapped you in the [ __ ] face
Oh rape yeah it sounds like it feels
like spiritual right because your dream
is attached to it we're imagining your
dream getting raped and there's nothing
you can do because you ask for the rape
right so now you're spiritually getting
raped and you go home and you lay in bed
and you know how a lot of the white
dudes back then we're good one day I'm
going again you know it someone like
Chris Pine I'm you know I'm gonna get a
right we're all and I want to blow up
right and us it's like one day nothing
nothing because there's nothing there
and then slowly we started working but
that's that changes with the time it has
to do with ad agencies it's when ad
agencies dude I do one ad agencies when
we should use more ethnic people and
commercials because Chinese people you
know eat like hamburgers to write that I
poked when they were doing that I booked
like 30 commercials a year for like
three years straight are you still with
Laurence yeah you still go out no but
I've been getting some like last year
Jordan Peele goes you know Jordan Peele
yeah yeah he calls me cuz he you still
do commercials
I got doing with you because me and
Keegan are doing one for I'm booking
comm Klose though yeah so I could get a
call and he goes all you have to do is
make out with Jane Lynch on a bed I
thought that's all I have to do I had a
couple lines I made out with Jane Lynch
on the bed all day
Tonka's the lesbian she's so funny
cool and at the end dude these lawyers
came up to me and they go can we talk to
you outside and they take me out and
they go did you say that black people
were oily on your podcast I go excuse me
did you say black people were oily I can
ah no I don't say that right you know
where was so on tiger belly my podcast I
did say black people oily and this black
lady trying to embezzle me for money she
wrote me a letter go if you don't send
me fifteen thousand dollars I'm gonna
ruin your career did she did that right
and every week she would get an email
fifteen thousand and she goes I know
you're doing commercial and I'm gonna
[ __ ] you out of that commercial if you
don't give me fifteen thousand dollars
right I show up at the Commission she
try to do it and at that point I went
home I didn't lose the commercial
because they go we know you do Tiger
Bella we know that we vet you
we know you're crazy but we love you
right
so I call my agent and we put a stop to
it
I got lawyers everyone involved we wrote
him a letter
blackmail I was I was gonna [ __ ] kill
this [ __ ] lady imagine work you you
work right I work you know the first
fifth twenty years fifteen years ten
years of your career you don't make any
money so you know you put all every
night you go up every night you put your
[ __ ] time in you get rejected open
mics open mics year after year after
year finally you get to a place where
they're making giving you money and some
[ __ ] [ __ ] is trying to [ __ ]
embezzle it in bezel you [ __ ] you
because you said black people oil yeah
but it's not even that bad and also not
only that I don't even know what it
means number one and number two the
episodes are before that I did a whole
episode of making fun of Mexican
and the episode before that we did to
action episodes of making fun of Asians
and on one episode I said one time black
people were oily and then if somebody
trying to embezzle me and blackmail me
for money it's crazy it's [ __ ] crazy
but dude imagine doing me tell you
something right now if I was on that
commercial because they were paying me a
lot of money doing and also Jordan put
his neck out for me
he's my friend right and one of him
little look like a fool he won an Oscar
for God's sake all right if I would have
lost that commercial because of this
random person that I don't [ __ ] know
I would have been like John wick bro I
would have got guns I would I would have
[ __ ] 100 this [ __ ] down no no
no see what we no no no I do not
understand over him it wasn't Tony
Bennett Tony Bennett what hold on was I
wanna give some shout out to my man Nick
Costello I'm sorry about your cat you
know I love you buddy thanks for being
part of the church Matt homier up there
Milwaukee Rob got a [ __ ] Rob got a
rock groove a loose top quality totally
I see you marks tournament pit stop
entertainment my Puerto Rican of the
Year Rene in kasi on my brother in
Chicago Bob alingas and his family my
main man rip Ripley and always one of
the page Scott Cunningham and my main
[ __ ] men dicks I yet don't
forget Utah Salt Lake City sold out this
weekend Kansas City here I come
August 9 Thursday night 8 o'clock myself
and Dean del Rizzi
Friday and Saturday let me tell you
something Thursday's your lucky [ __ ]
that night come Thursday you might bump
into Lindsay Lohan Lincoln balls she
stars a debt that somebody might give
you a seven dollar bag of heroin you
never know what a [ __ ] Churchill so
what you mean to tell me is this is what
you mean to tell me what I did time I
got left back I did all this dumb [ __ ] I
lived in my car I had a dream to just do
comedy as long as I can just do comedy
to not be a criminal I would have been
[ __ ] happy
I get into this car I drive across
country 28 [ __ ] times I get the hang
of this [ __ ]
I moved to LA the shoot of pilot the pod
don't get picked up I become a regular
at the store I worked my [ __ ] ass off
I got a few movies I start doing a
podcast everything [ __ ] gets better
then the road I get a left like special
everybody's a rock and roll it and
somebody's gonna come out from 1985 and
say my finger bang yeah I don't accept
that at all yeah that's what I'm saying
I don't accept I don't accept it I don't
accept that I don't give a [ __ ] how you
feel or what movements going on I do
Daleks I don't accept it either okay you
know what man we were all I could tell
you things I did 40 years ago I'd like
to tell you things I did 20 years ago
when I do those things are gonna know
because I just won't I'm a different
person Lisa I've done things I've done
things where I think that I could have
been arrested for a long time I know you
would have been arrested yeah yeah but I
can't name those folks yeah yeah yeah
I've done things that I'm ashamed of
I'll be too because I'm gonna say this
so in the last 16 years especially I've
been in the up and up bro for me my
glasses everything to me since I build
up the cocaine listen you and I both
don't like we spoke about the beginning
whether it's cocaine whether it's pills
hash addiction is a mental prison you
think a certain way you act a certain
way because god forbid your little
utopia gets broken grana wrong god
forbid somebody finds about how good I
feel he's 10 to 15 vicodins I meet the
day god forbid somebody picked out away
from us you know what you know what if
that lady yeah willow offered you that
deal 14 17 years ago when you are a
Viking it you saying like people oily
yeah you would've gave a 3030 thousand
just to go away because god forbid
who cares about the media yeah you
didn't want your attention to get out
there
Oh think about how different life is
yeah how lucky we are we're lucky so all
I know is I was the same boat as you
the ten last ten years of my life I've
been married I had a daughter I have a
full-time employee when I love dealies
they have employees family you know I
try to do the best I can a man at bars
you'll never see me on a VIP you don't
see me in Hollywood parties for Christ's
sake I Drive a Subaru
I do the road twice a month
because that's the best I can give you
that's what I do that's what some on
joints among a beat
yeah every other every ten days when
does this air by the way this is
tomorrow
I'm gonna be at Portland well helium win
this weekend oh [ __ ] that's what my
favorite [ __ ] Club I love that glove
yeah I taste some they used to have
potato tots now you know I hate ranch
dressing yeah but these [ __ ] to
the third axle level Oh were they put in
there they put that's got a bocce Korean
sauce what sir Sir Arthur sriracha South
Koreans Chinese through these Iraqis
Chinese Yemen Thank You versus are
called scaramouche from Marissa Italian
dog songs teramachi
what's it called sriracha sriracha it's
Chinese
yeah and they used to put Chinese ranch
dressing whoa mix it up at one night I
didn't know what I was eating at least I
got like to pay the ton like dip it in
the funk in the in the thing I hate and
after what I looked at the menu I saw
him flogged yourself afterward oh my god
after I saw ranch Sorachi I [ __ ] what
am I gonna do it wasn't that bad I got
to be closed-minded
but just think of I'm not gonna say two
lambs in places yeah just thick never
sit awake when when I hear about Harvey
Weinstein that probably wasn't it was a
bad person yeah actually thought he was
a better but I know thirty other
[ __ ] that were doing the same
thing otherwise they were doing let me
tell you something one of the second
biggest one was a sex on Hollywood was
the [ __ ] comple stall well yeah
I don't know people know that
it's now it's right well right now it's
a business now no its management and
stuff but back in the day it was
Deadwood it was like we ran it well we
got the oh my god god it was I saw one
night I saw I walked in the main room
it's dark and I see legs popping out on
the bottom girl's legs just sticking out
of where the booth is sort of half her
body was in the booth her legs were
saying it was pitch black and I looked
and there was blood everywhere and she
trying to kill herself in there okay and
I went to name who it is but she wasn't
she was a waitress this had to be hate
to use it a long time ago a long time
ago my choice she tried to kill herself
over a manager yes a black man yeah now
let me tell you how this story even gets
quit yet yeah I like that girl very much
not as a boyfriend but she was very
sweet she moved out here she was taking
naive by a manager who was suave he had
like a wife or a girlfriend yeah he's
like God but he was playing softly suave
and I saw him playing huh and you gonna
be safe I could just say when we say
black he's not like Kanye's more
no he's more Geordi LaForge black right
he was he is more like you know
enterprise you know he was like dry skin
tina turner's husband blue yes recent
reference I don't know I turn you know I
turn her no I know the name I couldn't I
know I know I know I know a guy let's
let's call I know but I'll tell you I'll
let me tell you this Donald Glover okay
you're gonna find out go over loud I
would you hear this okay so this is
early on at The Comedy Store career this
waitress tries to kill herself and I got
a taste on the [ __ ] him because I
really liked her and what I heard why
she tried to kill herself I never really
liked that guy anymore he disappeared
has about a funny story about him then
he popped back then he came back he is
later okay I never said nothing it was
none of my business you're gonna pick
your battles but I could tell em I'm
blind I'm buying coke from a couple of
different people I have an Armenian code
dealer
have Mexican cocktail I have a black
coat dealer I don't have another black
dog deal then one of those black coat
view this happens to be a chameleon look
at my eyes I know what it is yeah
possibly a chameleon SL SL he huh yes
the worst cocaine that you could have an
imagine he was always my last choice
because I confronted from him he would
get high and forget I even because he
was on pills I know who you're talking
about
it was the [ __ ] crate and I liked him
I liked him today was the worst comic in
the world but I liked him and he lived
two blocks from my house and even with
all my cocaine paranoia I could still
drive to his house and get a pack it was
like McDonald's of cooking right so I
would say to him hey leave me some coke
in your motorcycle so he would leave his
garage door open
millions of people would walk by and in
the motorcycle in the little booth
there'd be a package waiting for me so
he would call me the next day and say
did you take the package and I go no he
goes there's no money that he told him
about I didn't take the package and he
goes somebody [ __ ] took the package
this one from once but I always work
things out so it's New Year's Eve when I
go up there and I flip the thing open
and I got it my hips Joey
and I look up and it's that girl I tried
to kill herself at the store ten or
twelve years early and there looking
like no what the [ __ ] are you doing here
I'm waiting for you see is he upstairs
and I felt like saying didn't you try to
kill yourself over a different black guy
yeah [ __ ] ten years ago and now
you're another [ __ ] black guy wanna
hang yourself again whether you want to
pull a board day that I just walked out
of there like and I told him the next
day I called mumbling oh hey man you
can't [ __ ] with that chick you can't
hold the whole story but she tried to
kill herself over some black thing
before and he had a girlfriend you you
got 20 white women gonna chasing you
sure I will heart attack I try to take
her to a meeting right cuz I was sober
I'm driving down La Cienega she jumps
out of my car going [ __ ] 40 and never
saw her again all I was doing
it was like thinking that I was like
some sort of human trafficker or
something she goes you you want to go to
a meeting right and get sober said I
don't know much about him I go you're
gonna die so I try to be the good dude
she jumped out of my [ __ ] car 40
miles now yeah can I tell you is
something up funny about that guy the
manager though so he was doing comedy -
do you know that yes four years four
years so I didn't see him for years so
one day I get a call from this guy named
Tony Calabresi from San Diego because do
you want to judge a Comedy Competition
in Tucson Arizona so how am I gonna get
there he goes I have a private plane we
do the whole thing
so I fly to Tucson it's a huge comedy
competition and one of the judges next
thing I know this next guys from Orlando
right he's been doing comedy for two
weeks only ladies and gentlemen it's the
guy the black manager he doesn't know
I'm judging he comes up there he's been
doing it for 10 years at that time but
you try to pawn it off like he's just
fart trying to oh I tried them before -
he said he'd been doing over two weeks
he goes up he wasn't even that good but
then I gave him an 0 out of 1 out of a
10 ok did you fart that's so gross you
smell yeah yeah no you did if you don't
smell you yeah yeah I [ __ ] smell it
right now it is blowing it smells like
Cuban Sultan's yeah it's rude sorry
about that yeah yeah yeah yeah relax
right Jackson ya know what we talked
about we're talking about the guy you
didn't even listen to my story about
your heart and you judge them he would
say with broken your bag didn't pull
that off well before the internet you
could I guess right going don't be
please should do it all the time do
comedy for two years and go to leverage
at all yeah Tony trying to do yeah
people would do that all
no it's embarrassing and he came back
yeah I saw those lagoons they had a room
of bread and wood that I saw about he
asked me if he brightened I told my call
never heard of something bigger
yeah disappeared again he's somewhere
lifting money from somebody I was gonna
start with that of Monday night there
had to be 60 people with the original
somebody the belly when you whisper dude
it's so [ __ ] creepy it's in it
because he's a creepy stone I know but
the way you're doing it right now it's
like there was a bachelorette party I
don't never forget this there's a
thousand [ __ ] sex stories at that
store and this chick locked the other
group as she goes I hear that this place
is haunted
could you give me a tour and you know
how I'd do a couple spots I took it to
the belly roll no I didn't think nothing
of it
we go up to the belly room we come down
I take it to the main room and when we
get to the one spot I go that's two
offices she knows is that the back way
she goes let me go inside and pee real
quick I'll be right out so I went walked
and sat by the door mm-hmm I just like
I'm an ass ride coke in my pocket maybe
like a did to blast the next thing I
hear it go and come into here I gotta
show you something when I went in she
was completely thinking there's a little
couch in the girl a woman's bad place to
be a little couch at that she was
completely naked playing with a [ __ ]
yes they used to bats this [ __ ] there
was a woman down there on a Sunday they
used to go in there with a wig she was
really pretty but she put a wig on that
but I mean you're people blow jobs in
the back no yeah then she leaves and I
found out that they passed her around
good night and then she disappeared
there was a blonde girl that was down
there giving [ __ ] I think it let me
say something it was crazy it was
completely you can't wait you can't eat
any girl that wants to [ __ ] me at the
store I'm gonna tell you this I admit I
pulled up at the comp business before I
met my girlfriend five years six years
ago I pulled up at the [ __ ] parking
lot there was the hottest girl I've seen
in a long time
she goes hi I'm a big fan straight up
okay thank you
and she goes I live at Bakersfield can I
spin the night your house tonight I go
yeah she comes to my place for a week
right
she [ __ ] me for a week it was the best
it was a gift from God and then I'm at a
dinner with her and Akama calls me I
can't say who and he goes hey dude that
girl you're with I go yeah you guys
don't bring her around tonight I'm
bringing my girlfriend I don't yeah but
she's with me oh I've been [ __ ] her
too dude
right I hang up the phone I look at her
I go who else have you [ __ ] I'm not
kidding you dude it was like every paid
regular on the lip I mean it was I mean
everyone okay you [ __ ] all these guys
she says yeah apparently I was the last
one and there you know what's funny
two years later Russell Peters comes up
to me and goes hey you know I got ya did
you sleep with everyone that's why from
you can't hang out with girls that hang
out at comedy clubs
everyone's been inside that well you
look at me like that said this
conversation with a different friend of
mine about the same topic yeah about a
friend that we had and she called me and
said how is she doing I know I haven't
spoken for years I don't like I know the
last thing she probably wants if there
was talk to a comic yeah I go why she
goes why don't everybody bang her yeah
did that feel it boy I remember one
night I was over there like at nine I
was already living with Terry gutters
this is what I knew this girl was crazy
and she probably won't ok just broke
about Terry when I found out years ago
that you were seeing her I couldn't
believe it yeah because she was like the
hardest waitress we had right
I go she's [ __ ] that guy I was
unbelievable I'm just so happy that so
yeah
I mean imagine though like the hardest
one what the [ __ ] will be saying I was
right there damn it
Jesus I'm so high right now huh what we
told him I don't know yeah I forgot what
you were saying pick up a pie yeah pick
up a pie yeah Jesus Christ guys nobody
remembers she get off the phone Bobby
Lee you're on the [ __ ] podcast what
we talkin about him for my crazy women
yeah yeah oh yeah yeah girls that the
girls that get around yeah yeah you know
what man I'm happy and I saw some crazy
situations so early on 97 to 2000 and
Beyond on the road I've seen and heard
some crazy situations there was woman
five years ago right what are you
already living with Terry what's up
you're reliving with Terry right the
already and there was a girl does she
hit on you or something [ __ ] you don't
remember
no she's on release girl that slept with
every guy at the store oh no no no no no
we talked you know I don't know I was
living with Terry yeah and one morning I
got a call from this girl yeah then I
had those days they used to have parties
at this house a lot and I would stop by
to be nice on the way out because once I
went to the store and I got coke I
wasn't gonna go to your house to hang
out and I'm gonna do cope with them so I
would be nice and polite and go early on
when I was clear on [ __ ] but she was
already starting at drunk with her
girlfriends and I would go with his
saying hi he's doing thing all this they
had 10:30 at the store I wouldn't have a
spot no 11:45
I just wanting it out I was just trying
to be polite I never been its particular
that I was over there at 9:30 and I left
like at 10:15 10:30 and the next wallet
she caught me like that one and she was
hey you ever been like oh yeah she does
did you sleep with me last night
well and I go no I only went over there
at 9:00 she knows you weren't here at
4:00 but I don't know I was at my house
don't cook by myself and she goes okay
no problem she didn't know she had
[ __ ] Wow
scary that's some scary [ __ ] that's
every comedy scene has one that's why
I'm with just kalila that's why five
years time long time Bobby but I cannot
do it anymore who could do it not do it
it happened to 40 you have to feel bad
if you really abused women like that
have 240 a half 40 if you look at a
woman ago you know what I can be her dad
yeah like this is too easy I could be
her dad why would I want this on my
[ __ ] I'm my [ __ ] Yoshi
this is too easy I don't even jerk off
to like barely legal or any of those
kind of kind of horns it's about or not
any of that [ __ ] it's so crazy it's it's
it's it's unreal to me Lee I guarantee
you if I did like these seminars if I
got that greasy all right like I you
would say you Joey Diaz is coming to
your town 50 bucks all day Saturdays I
guarantee it that if I did 50 of them
I'd get approached that 50% of them by a
young comment asking me to take around
the road or we get together for quality
let me ask you this you think now
because of because you're selling out
rooms that whatnot you think right now
you could probably lend an 18 year old I
could do what do you think you can
[ __ ] 18 year old if you wanted to if
I put my mind to it lied and tricked you
and got drugs no I'm just based on your
fame and who you are you don't you could
know yeah yeah
there's no friend I'm a [ __ ] criminal
doesn't you know when you say that it's
ridiculous
I'm gonna stop stop there I wanna see
this I just wonder this anyone listening
all right because I'm gonna say this I
know this for a fact okay that when I
was calling CAA about having them rap
tiger belly which is my podcast they go
well how many to give me your number of
this and that and they go yeah you gotta
get to the church level before we're
interested right which tells me because
you know that you're at a different
place right so you're I know you're
trying to humble
yourself and go yeah I'm just a regular
guy which you are and you're a great guy
and I love you and I've always I'll
always love her no matter where you are
right but my point though is is that you
are you've elevated to a different level
can we just at least admit that we've
removed that all right well you wouldn't
know say that to me just say this repeat
after me
i Joey Diaz Joey Diaz have elevated
elevated to a god-like level to a
god-like you just said a different it to
a different all right good
outside and inside which is important
more on the outside more in the answer
then on the inside I still get [ __ ]
perverted thoughts [ __ ] people the end
and that's why it that's why I when you
texted me I came right over
because I love you but also your people
want to be on this thing people want to
be around you you deserve everything
that you have won't be right you I don't
know you see me to my house come years
ago what's crazy Bobby like the
difference between 15 years ago is now
is that you would go up to the store at
8:01 and I'd be at eight nine oh four
yeah that was it explains to Li what
it's like to go up to at 8 o'clock in
those days oh its head stayed till 2 it
was what do you mean there was death you
didn't like it you didn't like hanging
with re and torturing your friends back
when everybody was cool back when you
used to drive to San Diego yeah here's
what it is here's what it is I'm gonna
tell you what I'm gonna tell you where
I'm gonna tell you what it is when you
when you first okay imagine imagine
being at a job like I used to wait
tables in San Diego I used to get no
[ __ ] I had no future
I couldn't go to college oh I'm 21 22
and I have no my cars like the windows
are blasted open I got nothing
alright and you'd go to this job you
would work really hard and you would get
you know you would slave for 10 hours
straight slammed at a restaurant and you
get a hundred bucks as a tip right you
come home you get a burrito you go to
sleep and you wake up and you do it
again and then you see I had
[ __ ] friend I was working with his
band he was a [ __ ] and you know
midgets are they're so cute and so Ben
used to get way more [ __ ] than me and I
used to go I should kill myself you know
and I had nothing to live for and then
one day I walked by the comedy store and
there was an open mic and I signed up
and it went up and then nine months
later I was opening up for Pauly Shore
in front of 5,000 people at the Riviera
just imagine now from there boom all of
a sudden you're performing in front of
that many people
Mitsy comes up to me at the end of it
were in Vegas never met her before
because you're a regular at all my clubs
you're amazing and at that point now
your life changes you everything is
exciting then you're at the Comedy Store
you show up you run into guys like Dice
Clay Howie Mandel whoever it might be
mr. wood they sent you home cause he
last night I was working the door I was
working the door at the store at store
Andrew Dice Clay walks up to me I don't
even know him and he goes hey Ching get
in the car he used to call me Ching
right he didn't know my name for ten
years
everytime Ching and I go my name is
Bobby no you're Jing I go that's races
he goes no as [ __ ] Ching you got your
money right he tried to switch it up he
flies me first-class I have my Comedy
Store t-shirt on first-class to Las
Vegas right and he goes you're gonna be
my good luck charm he loses $750,000 in
in 24 hours it was I'd never see I mean
imagine having no money and then put way
was [ __ ] up upon it is the whole ride
over there it was like you're gonna get
10% of my winnings
so in my head is if he makes a million
dollars I'm gonna make a hundred grand
right but now he's down 750 right and he
goes go home I went home and he didn't
talk to me for years were you doing
and no I just went to Vegas to be as a
good luck charm
and it came home and it was it was I was
so depressed for like a year after that
but yeah that's that's the kind of [ __ ]
that wouldn't happen I'd ever tell you
that what happened with the Chinese the
Chinese sex party oh well let me get a
water no water no wrappers already open
when I get it yeah but I did that for a
reason he doesn't know what I did
listen what did you just do the mushroom
nothing everyday the Mexican government
ship said a hundred kilos a day a lot of
cocaine huh but they break it up they
ship 60 30 and then 3/10 60 33 33 yeah
they six they said 60 and then they sent
like 4/10 so 10 kilos on one meal 10
kilos on the other 10 kilos in the one
meal and the grand prize is the 60 they
may work with statistics and percentages
all right so they get one of those meals
get busted they lose 10 kilos but they
still get indict me so it doesn't matter
they include that in the profit so play
I gave me your [ __ ] everything well I
haven't hello but you see these elbows
here yeah they come a little butter
package so what I do is I open when I
pop them and I pop them for a purpose
because he thinks there's something in
them and like lastly [ __ ] with and we I
[ __ ] him because he lets me so if you
open that up look inside of that there's
a little butter pack yeah and let you
this I'm sorry I tell him listen I hope
when I put him in there reseals not
really
I'll do nothing so today last night I
got it with the spray bottles come are
they delicious are you [ __ ] up you
really do yeah so tonight I sprayed the
deactive Eisen and I hit a xanax a
little quarters annex to the bottom what
this annex he thought he was like an
inspector he thought he was like a
inspector but next thing you know he
swallowed the [ __ ] cat tranquilizer
so keep saying is really giving chemo
pills I already gave you two lights
you silly you got a girl or what no I'm
single now what happened oh we're
together for four and a half years I'm
not ready to get married
oh we're still close we're still friends
but he's been going on two dates lately
yeah boundaries are you high right now a
little bit yeah yeah you seem very high
right now so later with you are you
getting hot more high now cuz you seem a
little high right now he doesn't want to
stop like what are you sure because you
look a little uncomfortable do you one
of these gummies yet or what yeah yeah
that and uh something no what do you
mean we did sure
what's a mushroom cap just a little
mushroom and what does that do makes you
see things why do you do that now
because on a Monday because that's the
reason why I say both party wants
digital Friday professionals do show
yeah when you do get high and go on
stage or no you wait till afterwards no
I get how it goes yeah absolutely
but lately yeah you know what's funny
Bob sure you don't even know me for a
long time you said that when you can't
believe you're on the show more by then
the way you want to get off the road you
know what the role is our easiest
[ __ ] thing right I mean the role is
pressure because you have to sell that's
where the pressure comes it yeah but if
we take that pressure away the road is a
lot of [ __ ]
you know since my podcast that pressures
gone before it would it would be touch
and go some places I'm not selling any
tickets but now because I have taught
mutant tiger belly fans they come out
and I make great money and I get to see
my people and my people are good people
they're spiritual people don't [ __ ] up
but they're all like me you think half
their head shaving you know acne on
their face good titties you know they're
killing it
what are you looking at me like that for
because I learned one talking hey I see
the 20 years I've known everything you
grown as a man you're a [ __ ] kid with
a [ __ ] skateboard I never [ __ ] you
to question me
do you only like eight years old of them
in you were a kid with a skateboard
doing commie member you're a big-headed
Cuban dude what I might well [ __ ] just
flip the world on fire
you know man TV and then you give me
pills and I heard one day you pulled a
knife on you a [ __ ] coward Kawasaki
some [ __ ] and some [ __ ] on a
set which I thought was hilarious
don't you took carry yourself and you
build a different man just [ __ ]
journeys that people never get to when I
started this podcast the main theme of
this podcast Bobby Lee was not to look
down at people was to let people know
that we can be [ __ ] out and still
doing what the [ __ ] you dream yeah you
know you know this Netflix special I was
[ __ ] up like eight weeks if [ __ ] me up
bro what we're coming up to it if [ __ ]
me yeah coming up to it afterward it
[ __ ] me up kept me up at night a
couple months you know why why because I
started giving a [ __ ] that's right guys
like you me will Comedy Store Downey's
yeah we went up there with a plan but
that plan went away any other times our
balls will come out sometimes we take
our t-shirt though yeah sometimes you
turn on the audience and that's what may
Bobby Lee Bobby Lee and Joey Diaz Joey
Diaz you know what happened to me I saw
John mulaney's stand-up special it was
pretty good we just got a great writer
great writer yeah well guess what
what I'm not
Mulaney and neither was Bobby Lee you
know why because Bobby Lee is Bobby Lee
yeah oh it is Jo yeah yeah yeah you know
Jim Norton said something once but I
thought was kind of selfish and now
after it happened to me I see it's not
selfish he said I don't try to watch
some other people's specials and I
thought that that was a selfish thing
and I and now I know why because when I
watch John Mulaney and his profession it
destroyed my inside somewhat that there
was a [ __ ] jokes I'm 55 years old I'm
talking about you know some list of that
yeah it's colorful it's cute but John
mulaney's doing real stand-up family and
some Saint let me answer yeah yeah but
that now I'm okay you know why why I'm
going to the store from now on
exclusively yeah that's it that's it I'm
gonna die at the store I'm on the road
even if I go there once a week it's
better than going to any other place for
me yeah I've been doing comedy for too
long I'll be [ __ ] around and the
stores my home yeah when you see a void
when you see people like that you know
what it is is that there's different
styles right it's like you see guys like
John Mulaney
Neal Brennan Ryder [ __ ] you good yeah
there so yeah they thought it they they
do they can do voices they do really
smart like high concept pieces and mine
is more guttural you know I'm more like
he'll be eating [ __ ] and some you know
I have some things that even some comics
go that's a smart bit but in general I
do switches and all that but you know
what do at the end of the day it's like
I I I can only do what I do
right I can't be anyone else so if I
look at somebody else and I go oh yeah
that's great I just can't do that anyway
all right but you know what I'll be
honest with you there are a lot of
people that can't do what I do that's
what I'm saying yeah they people you
know I can go up there and get a laugh
without even saying anything right I
could just do like a little dance or
make a sound effects or do a little pose
or you do and people just laugh and I
got you know I challenge myself every
time I go get a couple of laughs before
you even say anything
challenge yourself and I learned how to
do it right like I'll do a wink and I'll
kissing you know do a little to a guy
and people will start laughing I mean
look and make a noise they start
laughing Orly I'll do gibberish you know
what makes Chris D'Elia laugh when I go
I get back I think I'm having no what I
add to it there it's open that way if
people start laughing so I just do my
own thing and you know what at the end
of the day people on the internet call
Bobby Lee's a loser
we hasn't done his [ __ ] since Matt and I
read [ __ ] right you know he lied some
girl does he's so ugly physically on one
of my posts and I read all that stuff
and you know sometimes I just go hmm but
you don't want at the end of the day I'm
making a good living I keep working and
who's right who's wrong
Oh Jess who is a father that's what the
last couple of times I went to this
store I haven't given a [ __ ] and when I
get that God feels good yeah it feels
good to go on stage you know what I'm
sorry you paid 25 bucks but if you don't
laughter that at least you got to save
me
yeah that's what God is all about you
has seen me it's gonna say you know
scary it is there to follow you though I
was no I give up I was backstage the
store no but I was backstage following
you and I'm learning on the road I know
I'm just saying though you're a beast
bro
I love it I love know about what people
have to follow you it's so [ __ ] scary
what time this door trades Bobby Lee
what the [ __ ] did you expect if I sent
you into your army that's one thing but
if I take you to arrange your training
and put you through helicopter and
killing the short missiles and killing
with small weapons and big weapons and
medium-range weapons I've created a
pretty deadly killer
we met at the store for 20 years I don't
know if you know this that makes you a
pretty deadly killer go home tonight and
your project for the next two weeks is
to grab a notebook and who you following
the people you have learned something
there okay Eddie Murphy tomorrow
all right Lee are you okay yeah he's
fine
yeah but you you just seem you're
drifting in and out of that's actually
does every day I know but you you you
looked over there and then you started
thinking about something a little [ __ ]
he's not [ __ ]
no he's just hot I've been having the
tested here but I guess the tranquilizer
all googly-eyed right now yeah yeah yeah
he's fine
yeah he's a good man but it's just weird
it's great though the other I walked in
I'm watching you and like I said just
saw shame I did not know it you were
gonna be on that show I just needed a
spot I wanted to get out of the house so
I called it and there you were and I'm
like let me watch this [ __ ] and
I was laughing and that that I drove
home and I'm like this is amazing
I don't know if he knows how lucky we
are no I I now know I know
I now know and I believe this is what I
really believe that we our generation is
now hitting a stride I can see it oh
yeah because when we were when I was
struggling was you me Ari Shaffir all of
those guys Callen right and now we've
all hit this podcast world which is
opened us up man it really has I mean I
want to show but that's because you know
you know I have my pod I have my [ __ ]
going but like five years ago there was
a drought I couldn't get nothing going
even on the road it wasn't happening
right I was like but now selling out
getting [ __ ] and it's all because my
generation which is you we're doing this
podcast [ __ ] revealing ourselves saying
things that we shouldn't be saying but
still like this is the most freeing
thing I've ever done in my career which
is this podcast [ __ ] I love it I love it
too dude because we get to go be
together as a family I get to see your
little conflicting Cuban titties
sticking out of that white shirt you
like that not really no what do you do
nothing but your titties together two
blocks around the corner
tuxedo the because little [ __ ] green
little titties there moon
oh he's fun he's got the [ __ ] he got a
little good titties huh
he's got of the what's the guy that
killed the two pot baby yeah you got big
his little white tinted sure Bobby Lee
you at helium important yeah and then
way yeah after that I'm done I'm
shooting my shell I was I can see it's
filling up the other baby thing where
can people find you tiger belly my
podcast and Bobby Lee live on all my
socials man its Tiger Bowie on iTunes
it's on iTunes all things comedy the
whole thing yeah listen it's always a
pleasure seeing you I love you I write
up here I love it I love you that don't
forget you filthy [ __ ] animals Kansas
City
August 9th to the 11th it's gonna be a
[ __ ] hoot Thursday nights tonight
we're gonna get this party started with
a lot of [ __ ] do to Lutz and took two
needs you know I'm saying Lee y'all
right over there oh you don't look good
you looking pale number one let me
explain something to you people blue
apron deliveries is a complicit forget
about what they do blue aprons mission
is to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everyone
blue apron achieves this by supporting a
more sustainable food system setting the
highest standards for ingredients and
building a community of home chefs not
leave you got some what would you get
last time last time I got these Philly
cheesesteaks Korean beef rice bowl and a
pasta dish it was delicious
every night on my girlfriend look but
makes me makes me blue apron come talk
it's the best product that's the best
product out there let me tell what the
menu is this week you got Chrissy Teigen
chipotle lime chicken fajitas with
sauteed mushrooms and sweet peppers ooh
you got barbecue vegetable flatbread
with Swiss cheese oh my god and a
customer favorite sweet chili beef with
vegetable stir-fry with garlic rice and
you ready for this one
honey Chipotle glazed chicken with
poblano and lime rice this is what I'm
talking about talk to you people about
skip the meal planning and get straight
to cooking with blue apron you
understand me and smoky depth to your
dinner wanna join the warm weather and
those perfect grill marks with
incredible grease and chef design
recipes blue apron lets you see the
power of what food can do alright listen
it's delicious so what I want you to do
is check out this week's menu like I
told you I'm gonna give you your first
three meals for free
at blue apron comm slash Joey again
that's blue apron comm slash Joey we
offer you twelve new recipes each week
and a customer can pick two three or
four recipes based on what fits that
schedule blue apron only sends GMO non
ingredients with meat with no added
hormones so again go to blue apron comm
slash Joey that's blue apron comm slash
Joey to get your first three meals free
blue apron it's a better way to cook
number two let me tell you something
hiring used to be hard multiple job
sites stacks of resumes a confusing
review process but today hiring can be
easy and you have to go to one place to
get it done you ready for this one zip
recruiter com
what'd you say Joey zip recruiter Tom
what who's there at the door zip
recruiter dot-com
zip we could have sent your job to over
a hundred of the web's leading job
boards but they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
zip recruited scans thousands of resumes
to find people with the right experience
and invite them to apply to your job
that's one trying to tell you as
applicants come in the zip recruit
analyzes everybody and spotlights the
top candidates so you never miss a great
match all right zip recruit is so
effective then 80% again 80% again any
percent of employees who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site you ready for this one
within one day that's crazy that's crazy
that that's that's how great zip recruit
is so what I want you to do is this all
right with the results like that it's no
wonder zip recruiter is the highest
rated hiring site in America that's
right you heard it here in the church
the highest rating and hiring site in
America right now the church family it
cries zip recruit
for free gratis nothing at this
exclusive web radness i want you to go
to zip recruiter comm slash